من فلوريدا يعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترشحه للمره الثالثه لسباق الرئاسه وفي
فلوريدا ايضا تدور معركه الزعامه على
الحزب الجمهوري امريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جديده من جديد
وسنجعلها عظيمه من جديد
ترامب لوح بهذا الاعلان منذ فتره حتى قبل
الانتخابات النصفيه الا انهم طبر ولو ليس
كثيرا بعد اسبوع فقط على نتائج نصفيه لم
تجلب الموجه الحمراء التي اشهرها مضافي
اعلانه قبل عينين على موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وبمعزل عن توصيات من مقربين له
بالتاجيل
[تصفيق]
البعض يرى في اسراع ترامب كسبا لعامل
الزمن اما انتخابيا او قضائيا فعلى الصعيد
القانوني يحوم الشبح التحقيقات المتعدده
المفتوحه في شركات ترامب والاهم تفتيش مقر
اقامته من قبل الاف بي اي وتحقيقات وزاره
العدل في اخذه وثائق سريه بعد مغادرته
الرئاسه اما انتخابيه فيبر حاكم ولايات
فلوريدا خصمان سياسيا محتملا في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوريه
التوتر وما بين ترامب في الايام التي سبقت
الانتخابات فلم يبعد سانتوس لتجمع اقامه
ترامب لمرشحين من فلوريداب
وبعدها خسارات متلاحقه لمرشحين انتقاهم
ترامب في نفسه ودعمهم في ولايات متارجحه
وهامه من اريزونا الى بنسلفانيا الى منشن
مقارنه بادائد سانتوس القوي في فلوريدا
باتت اصوات جمهوريه واعلاميه تصفه بالزعيم
الجديد للحزب الجمهوري ترامب اطلق وابل
غضبه على دسنتس ليرد الاخير
انتخابات الثلاثاء
[تصفيق]
على اسماء تم تداولها للترشح للرئاسه
اضافه الى ديسمبر
الذي بدا يتحدث للاعلام عن غضبه من هجوم
ترامب عليه يوم اقتحام الكونغرس في السادس
من يناير الى وزير خارجيه السابق
ارى ان ترامب سيواجهه في الانتخابات
التمهيديه ومن سيترشح ضده سيلقى دعما من
قطاع واسع من قياده الحزب الجمهوري
وارشح انهم ادركوا الان بان لدى ترامب
قاعده واسعه من المؤيدين واموال اطلاق
حمله انتخابه جديه وانه من غير الوارد ان
يختفي هكذا ولذا فان عليهم التنسيق لدعم
المرشح او اثنين
سابقا قابل اعلانه بالفطور صحيفه اليمنيه
عن ولد صفحتها الاولى رجل من فلوريدا
يتقدم باعلان في حين نشرت فوكس نيوز على
موقع التابعي لترامب قائله ان كبارا
المتبرعين يريدون المضيء بعيدا عن ترامب
الذي خسر ثلاث مرات اما ناشونال ريفيو
المياله للمحافظين صعنوا على افتتاحيتها
حول ترشح ترامب بكله
بخيبه امل الجمهوريين في تحقيق فوز ساحقا
في الانتخابات النصفيه لكن اخرين يرون ان
ترامب تمكنا في الماضي من تخطي الصعاب
وانه من السابق لاوانه اصداره حكم نهائيا
اذا مستقبله السياسيه الجزيره